i just love you and by the way you also
like have been doing this fun thing
like well i mean just doing this fun
thing you have like five million
followers
on tick tock and my girls love tik tok
and i feel like of all the social media
apps i'm kind of like
the most down with it because it isn't
so much about like
a pose and a filter and lack of
attainability it's
it's a little bit more expressive and
theatrical and
humorous and you know inventive and so
i'm you know i love it i like that
yeah i like the creativity with with it
and
it forces them to be like editors and
directors
yes exactly i don't have a tic tock
account we're going to open one for the
show i've never been on it
and i was wondering it's so fun well
will you
teach me yeah can we do it right now
tick tock dance yeah
yeah for sure all right this is the
video we're gonna do this is with you
and sofia vergara who i just love oh
yeah
i taught her at the vanity fair party
how to do it i think i'm
probably gonna be like imitating you
because you're my teacher
and i'm gonna be doing it badly so just
you know
what you see in the mirror of me is not
what other people see with you they're
oh they're but i'm my own animal here
and that's that's also the thing you
can't really mess up
like that's what's also great is like
it's so inclusive of so many kind of
people so i'm going to stand up over
here
okay and i'm going to come down here all
right we're going to cue the music up
and i'm going to do my first ever
tick talk with you miss alba
so now you're going to get me started
here so the biggest thing is for you to
start on the same
side so if we both go to the right say
at the same time okay so it's one
two three but it's like one two
three hands up one two
three hands behind the head one two
three hands on the hip one two
three okay it's just three it's pretty
easy
all right i'm ready hit me give me
by the way i'm not kidding i think the
look on my face was this
and then all of a sudden all right one
more time
this time i will try to actually be
semi-sexual
like or semi-sexy you don't have to do
any of that
no it's just it's just having fun here
we go
all right cue the music steve here we go
um oh my god jessica thank you so much
i want to have so many firsts thank you
[Music]
you